[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous je suis en au chu et
après mûre réflexion j'ai décidé de vous
parler d'une plante qui s'appelle l'iso
être lacustre vous avez ici en photo en
latin il souhaite s lacustre hills c'est
une plante qui pousse au fond de l'eau
dans quelques lacs en france dans les
pyrénées auvergne dans les vosges
elle aime les eaux froides pur acide
très pauvre en nutriments
c'est une plante qu'on appelle reliques
de l'époque la crl a connu son heure de
gloire lors de la dernière époque
glaciaire et puis à mesure que le climat
s'est réchauffé
cette plante a commencé à se raréfier
parce que son milieu disparaissait
pourquoi est-ce que je vous parle de
cette plante simplement parce que cette
plante la gelée découverte quand j'avais
17 ans et aujourd'hui j'en ai 40
ça fait 23 ans que cette plante me
fascine
ça fait 23 ans que je parcours la france
l'europe pour la trouver lé porte pour
trouver ses congénères je ne saurais pas
vous dire pourquoi
toujours est il que je trouve cette
plante terriblement esthétique tout en
elle me semble bout sa couleur sa forme
son écologie son histoire est forcément
si je vous demande à vous si vous si
vous la trouvez belle vous allez me dire
oui ben c'est une touffe d'herbe qui
pousse au fond de l'eau il vous aurait
parfaitement raison parce qu'en plus
c'est une fougère
c'est à dire qu'elle n'est pas de fleurs
donc elles restent désespérément verte
et vraies raisons pour lesquelles je
vous parle de cette plante
la première c'est que c'est sans doute
la première et la dernière fois pour
parle des zizou est dans un tête et ça
c'est une immense satisfaction pour un
botaniste
et la deuxième raison c'est que c'est ma
manière à moi de vous souhaiter la
bienvenue dans le monde de la vie et
l'univers d'un euro atypiques tels que
moi alors qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'un euro
atypique alors atypique c'est pas
systématiquement quelqu'un qui aime les
plantes moche un euro atypique
c'est quelqu'un qui a un système nerveux
qui est différent qui a un cerveau qui
est différent pour ainsi dire le
hardware ne fonctionne pas comme pour
tout le monde alors il peut être autiste
qui peut être au potentiel intellectuel
il peut souffrir d'un trouble
déficitaire de l'attention le td à je
reviendrai tout à l'heure il peut être
hyperactif et peut être hyper sensible
il peut être dyslexiques 10 graphique
j'en oubliais toujours est il que toutes
ces particularités là toutes ces
différences neurologie quand on les met
bout à bout on estime qu'en france ça
représente environ 15% de la population
donc une personne sur six ou sept dans
le hardware est différent à des degrés
divers et pour que vous compreniez dans
le détail ce que signifie être un héros
atypique au delà de l'exemple de l'isu
est je vais vous livrer quelques
anecdotes tirées de ma vie quotidienne
pour que vous sachiez tous il ya deux
ans j'ai été diagnostiqués souffrant
d'un trouble déficitaire de l'attention
le td a dont je parlais tout à l'heure
on a identifié au potentiel intellectuel
et on a également identifié un certain
nombre de traits du spectre autistique
alors sans pour autant que je sois
autistes cliniquement il ya quand même
un certain nombre un indice qui laisse
entendre qu'il ya des choses qui sur ce
terrain là sont ambigus exemples tirés
de la vie quotidienne je commence
systématiquement mais journée par un
petit déjeuner à base de café et
cigarettes à la fin de la matinée j'ai
dû fumer une quinzaine de clopes
j'ai bu trois café allongé environ dans
chaque café allongé et gémit provençaux
de sucre c'est à dire qu'à la fin de la
matinée j'ai quand même consommé une
petite dizaine de morceaux de sucre
autant vous dire que je fini sur les
rotules temps vous dire que je tremble
vu que c'est pas très bon pour ma santé
je le sais je suis allé voir une
addictologues et cet édito lon même m'a
dit votre problème monsieur chaput c'est
le trouble déficitaire de l'attention
un trouble déficitaire de l'attention
c'est un déséquilibre chimique dans le
cerveau qui empêche mon cerveau de se
concentrer durablement sur une tâche
je commence quelque chose et puis une
autre idée mme bien donc je change
et c est le premier que le cerveau ou
ccc qui doit se concentrer
donc logiquement il me commande de gober
des substances psycho stimulante caféine
nicotine et c'est saccharose oms et 7
assists icm ont prouvé que les personnes
atteintes d'un trouble déficitaire de
l'attention sont plus sensibles aux
addictions
ça c'est l'une des étés des conséquences
immédiatement visible du trouble
déficitaire de l'attention sur sur la
vie il y en a d'autres
j'ai les plus grandes difficultés du
monde à lire un roman par exemple parce
que je ne parviens pas à fixer mon
attention lorsque je commence une tâche
j'ai du mal à la terminer je suis d
organiser dans mon cas en plus et s'est
aggravée par l'une des particularités de
beaucoup de personnes au potentiel c'est
pour rappel la pensée arborescentes
c'est à dire une idée vient et puis elle
en entraîne une deuxième qu'elle
entraîne une troisième et puis commence
à y avoir des bifurcations sa de vaincre
totalement président là encore c'était
organisé ça n'a rien de linéaire et
autant vous dire dans la vie quotidienne
notamment la vie professionnelle
c'est assez handicapant je vais vous
donner une anecdote je me trouvais dans
un restaurant à côté d'un couple j'étais
en train de travailler en mangeant et
pendant ce temps-là j'écoutais quand
même la condamnation du couple à côté
qui était pas très intéressant mais bon
et à un moment là la discussion devient
très intéressante parce que le mec
commence à parler de sa double
comptabilité et il en parle en baissant
la voix est si je suis devenu
franchement un discret c'est parce qu'il
avait commencé à baisser la voix et là
j'ai eu envie de lui dire mec tu te
rends pas compte
tu as pensé être plus discret parce que
voilà tout changer de prosodie
mais non c'est juste c'est justement ce
qui a été le déclic
demont indiscrétions je ne lui ai pas
dit parce que j'avais reçue plutôt
timide mais tout de même durant une
heure après j'ai lâché tout ce que je
devais faire et je me suis amusé à
lister analysé classer toutes les
raisons pour lesquelles on est un
discret en terrasse de café
autant vous dire que j'ai pas du tout
avancé sur mon travail pas du tout mais
toujours est-il que je me suis éclaté
vraiment alors il ya des dimensions sur
le sol sur lesquels m au quotidien je
m'éclate beaucoup moins c'est le
relationnel
prenons par exemple cet ami qui
m'appelle un matin mes amis savent que
je n'aime pas le téléphone et que chaque
coup de fil doit commencer par la
réponse à la question
voilà pourquoi je m'appelle c'est un
rituel c'est comme ça et elle en réponse
à cette question là elle m'a dit rien
pour prendre des nouvelles
et là j'ai senti monter une sorte de
bouffée d'angoissé tout simplement parce
que j'ai la phobie de ce qu'on appelle
les small tox petite conversation sur
tout et rien ski qui cimente 1 les
amitiés et les relations moi ça
m'angoisse profondément ça m'angoisse
profondément et c est cette
irrépressible
j'ai envie de raccrocher j'ai envie de
fuir alors quelque chose comme ça je
peux l'expliquer à mes amis je peux leur
dire bon voilà si vous venez me voir
pour me raconter votre journée c'est pas
la peine dans un certain nombre de
difficultés d'un certain nombre de
situations sociales
je peux pas faire ce travail
d'explication prenons par exemple cet
anniversaire auxquelles j'étais il ya
quelques mois j'avais au préalable de me
demander à l'ami qui organise les
anniversaires comme une personne sera
présente
parce que bien évidemment j'ai là j'ai
la phobie des environnements sociaux
entre parenthèses je vous laisse
imaginer dans quel état je suis là
maintenant
donc ma vie dit voilà il y aura une
trentaine de personnes j'avais intégré
ça vient d'intégrer ça et je me disais
tout va bien se passer
j'arrive dans le bar et forcément je
passe une demi heure prostré dans un
coin
au bout d'une demi heure il vient
convives qui qui vient me parler et là
la conversation immédiatement porte sur
dheune giovanni l'opéra de mozart jeudi
génial une conversation intéressante on
parlera pas de 1 bastia qui se tuent
fait aux prochaines vacances et dans la
vigne et la magie commence à parler de
don giovanni et j'ai oublié une seule
chose c'est que quand on est présent un
anniversaire c'est en général pour faire
la fête boire du champagne pour passer
un bon moment
voilà
et le temps que je m'en rende compte mon
interlocuteur était déjà parti on avait
planté là le problème dans ce genre de
situation c'est que je ne suis pas
capable de détecter naturellement
l'ennui chez l'autre c'est un
automatisme qui me manque donc donc il
faut que j'y réfléchisse il faut que
j'analyse ce qu'il fait son visage son
expression etc et là j'étais tellement
absorbés par le sujet que j'ai
totalement oublié de faire gaffe et je
me retrouvais franchement idiot
cette question des automatismes pour moi
en tant que droit typique elle est
fondamentale dans la mesure où comme je
ne sais pas dans de nombreuses
situations comment me comporter je suis
obligé d'analysé une autre anecdote je
ne me trouvaient toujours dans un
restaurant où il y avait une actrice
française c'est là qu'ils s'appellent
mélanie houle s est blonde et allah et à
la fin de son déjeuner elle traverse la
salle du restaurant tout en me fixant
dans les yeux et en 3 secondes et 3
secondes c'est extrêmement qu'est ce que
j'ai fait je n'ai ni je n'ai pas souri
et je n'ai pas baissé les yeux
je vais regarder et pendant ce temps là
le logiciel tournée j'ai commencé par me
permet de scanner pour savoir si j'avais
un épi ou un bouton sur le nez ou une
tâche des terres avant après j'ai
continué de déployer lors de décisions
pour étudier différentes hypothèses
est ce qu'elle me trouve tellement
hideuse que elle en est est-ce que
scotché est ce qu'elle est ce que je
trouve bizarre ce qu'elle trouve le
problème c'est que le temps de déployer
sa tarte de décision la mélanie en
question a été partie tout ça pour vous
dire que des réactions instinctives que
ce soit sourire ou baisser les yeux moi
je les balais complètement je remplace
sa part de l'hyper analyse j'analyse en
permanence autant vous dire qu'à la fin
de la journée je suis totalement épuisé
ça ne veut pas dire que je ne peux pas
être instinctif je peux l'être
instinctif mais ce soir là c'est à mes
risques et périls
parce que comme beaucoup de haut
potentiel intellectuel je suis un
hypersensible
c'est à dire que je suis capable d'être
envahi contaminés par mes émotions
notamment au travail gt
piquer des crises de colère dans des
situations soit absurde soit injuste
soit inefficace et donc gg développé
avec le temps une amende totale de
spontanéité qui fait que je suis obligé
en permanence de faire tourner le
logiciel pour comprendre ce que les gens
pensent et comprendre ce que les gens
veulent
au-delà de ces anecdotes je passe sur
toute une série de petites bizarreries
du quotidien des petits détails le fait
que lorsque pas plus tard que ce matin
lorsque j'entends le jingle de la sncf
je suis obligé de le 2-2 le chantait
savez tintin ou lorsque je vois un chat
un chien une chèvre un auteur ou une
vache est obligé de limiter le crie mon
aversion complète pour le contact des
vêtements mouillés sur la peau ou le
contact des amandes mondées monde et
sont mes dents qui me mettre dans des
états de stress extrême ou à contrario
des passions telle que l'isu est qu'ils
étaient là où les orchidées ou l'ancien
hymne impérial autrichien ou plein de
choses voilà alors chacune de ces
anecdotes chacun de ces détails ne sont
significatives de rien ne révèle rien en
revanche quand on les met bout à bout et
quand on y adjoint d évaluation
notamment par des neuropsychologues
alors ils révèlent quelque chose et là
la différence sensation de décalage que
je vis depuis allez que je suis en âge
de conscience on me dit ce n'est pas
seulement un certain sentiment tu
réellement différent parce que tu as
neurologie est différente
ces éléments de récits personnels
un autre neuro atypique vous en donnerai
d'autres il aura sa propre expérience
il aura il aura sa propre ses propres
difficultés sa propre souffrance
moi j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir faire
des grandes études il ya beaucoup de
hauts potentiels qui ne pouvait pas
faire de grandes études parce que le
système éducatif était n'était pas
adapté mais tous ont en commun aux
règles très général cette différence et
cette sensation de décalage l'événement
libérateur aller à pau
ça le diagnostic le moment où un expert
vous dis voilà notre différence elle et
neurologiques c'est très libérateur et
la gestion de cette différence ensuite
elle se passe en trois temps passés
présents et futurs
le passé c'est tout simplement la
réinterprétation de son histoire de ses
passions de ses échecs de ses victoires
sur professionnels estudiantin ou
amoureux s'est arrêté de se reprocher d
échec parce que dans de nombreux cas ces
échecs étaient expliquées justement par
une différence qui ne relève pas de
l'absurde vend pas de la volonté
le présent c'est tenir compte de cette
différence pour adapter son
environnement sur l'environnement de
travail par exemple si je ne supporte
pas les réunions qui durent plus d'une
heure eh ben ce moment là je vais faire
en sorte de dire mes interlocuteurs
voilà la réunion durera au maximum une
heure
je peux également expliquer à mes amis
que je suis différent donc qu'il ya des
choses qui ne faut pas chercher à
comprendre il faut les accepter
et pour vous montrer à quel point sur
cette question de l'aide de lettres de
la différence le regard des autres et
même de la société dans son ensemble
était absolument fondamental je vais
vous donner l'exemple des gauchers il ya
quelques décennies encore à l'école ont
considéré qu'un enfant qui était gaucher
c'est anormal
donc on le forçait à écrire la main
droite
c'est ce qu'on appelle les gauchers
contrariés la plupart du temps c'était à
l'origine de très grande souffrance de
la part de ces fameux gauchers
contrariés
tout simplement parce qu'on partait du
principe que c'était une anomalie et
qu'une anomalie ça se corrige
aujourd'hui ne viendrait plus du tout à
l'idée d'un enseignant de forcer un
enfant gaucher à écrire de la main
droite
merci de telle sorte qu'on accomplit
glisser progressivement de l'anomalie
vers la différence et donc de la
nécessité de corriger vers l'acceptation
le troisième temps de la gestion de la
différence c'est le futur c'est comment
est-ce qu'on transforme cette différence
objective en quelque chose de positif
parce qu'en réalité être neuro atypique
ce n'est pas seulement avoir des
difficultés relationnelles ou des
passions un peu enfermante c'est
également avoir de vrais atouts par
exemple moi je sais que je suis très
douée sur tout ce qui est écriture
beaucoup moins à l'oral je suis très
douée envisage visualisation 3d un
exemple ma meilleure amie et son mari
vont dans une galerie d'art et là il
flashe sur un sera tableau qui
représente un très grand tableau qui
représente la nef d'une cathédrale et le
galeriste l'heure du goûter ya aucun
problème je vois que vous hésitez
je vais amener le tableau chez vous
comme ça vous pourrez le voir et donc le
galeriste vie est belle et bien moi je
suis avec eux dans l'appartement cariste
installe le tableau est là tout le monde
regarde le tableau 7,9 de cathédrales
absolument magnifique
mes amis ont vraiment les yeux qui
brillent on sent qu'ils veulent acheter
le tableau
le galeriste à côté elle semble qu'ils
sourire en coin je le vois édiles c'est
bon c'est dans la poche et la mort jeudi
mais attendez y'a pas une erreur de
perspective
il y avait une monumentale erreur de
perspective sur le plafond de la nef de
la cathédrale et à partir de ce moment
là mes amis n'ont plus vu que l'erreur
de perspectives le galeriste plémy et
est reparti avec son tableau sous le
bras
mes amis auraient vu tôt ou tard
l'erreur de perspectives parce qu'elle
était grossière et moi mon talent dans
cette affaire ça a été immédiatement de
la repérer et de leur faire remarquer
qu'il y avait une erreur avant qu'ils
dépensent des millions d'euros dans
l'achat d'un tableau
cette question d hyper compétences voilà
à cet exemple est un peu anecdotique
mais la question des hyper compétences
des personnes en europe atypique est au
coeur d'un mouvement
tian qui est en train de se développer
aux états unis ou en france en france il
ya par exemple une société qui s'appelle
outils consult qui est spécialisée dans
les prestations de conseil en
informatique et qui fait travailler que
des autistes et les clients sont ravis
fabuleux cazalis kincaid chercheuse au
cnrs concentre ses recherches sur les
autistes spécifiquement par le prisme de
la rippe la compétence et le projet que
je monte moi-même qui s'appelle flamengo
stone avec d'autres amis noro atypique a
également vocation à mettre en évidence
et à valoriser les hyper compétences des
normes atypique alors pour conclure si
vous devez retenir une chose c'est que
voilà les noms atypique c'est une
personne sur six ou sept dans votre
entourage il y en a nécessairement
elles ne le savent pas nécessairement
accueilli cette différence avec
bienveillance indulgence et voyez la
même même comme une richesse à la fois
pour vous en amour en amitié ou pour une
société une entreprise ou pour la
société dans son ensemble a minima
ça vous permettra par exemple
d'économiser des milliers d'euros dans
l'achat d'une peinture avec une énorme
erreur de perspective vous remercie
[Applaudissements]